good morning Hank it's Sunday July
something Hank by now I think we've
established that nerdfighters should not
treat the vlogbrothers as a calendar and
today we're gonna talk about Iran and
monolithic enemies but first let's talk
about what shawne's up to in Bangladesh
so Hank Neuer nerdfighters may not know
this but we have a guy in Bangladesh
named Sean who's boning poverty for us
well not just for us also with us
because he uses our money to help poem
the poverty Sean has an amazing new
video about what he's doing in
Bangladesh these days check it out in
the sidebar god I hope it's over this
way don't have any spatial intelligence
I always point in the wrong direction so
like since I made a video about the
rigged presidential election in Iran a
few weeks ago I've been reading a lot of
amazingly stupid YouTube comments
Hank I know a lot of people think that
it's redundant to say amazingly stupid
YouTube comments and that I could just
have shortened it to YouTube comments
but the fact is that nerdfighter
comments on YouTube are generally so
thoughtful and respectful that I'm
always kind of shocked when the non
nerdfighters show up and they're all
giant squids of anger Eli so we've just
to clear things up I want to answer a
few questions and I apologize in advance
if I start ranting 1 why do you care
about Iran Iran is Iran's problem why
don't you care about America ok caring
about America and caring about Iran are
not mutually exclusive it's not like
Iran is pirates and America is ninjas
and we all have to pick sides between
them ninjas it is true that Iranians
have to solve Iran's problems in the
same way that Americans have to solve
America's problems but it's amazingly
stupid to pretend that America and Iran
don't have anything to do with one
another
I mean we share a frickin planet I like
the planet in terms of places I might
live this planet is like my second
favorite after Mars and I would totally
go live on Mars and stop worrying about
America and Iran but unfortunately I'm
no good at terraforming nerd jokes nerd
jokes nerd jokes number two don't you
know it doesn't matter the president of
Iran is because no matter who is
president the same Grand Ayatollah will
still be the supreme leader yes I do
understand that but it still matters who
the president of Iran is first off it
matters to the Iranian people because
Ahmadinejad has single-handedly ruined
the Iranian economy and has let loose
these horrifying morality police second
off it matters to the world because
or Ahmadinejad was president they had a
less crazy president and things were
better between Iran and the rest of the
world third what does it matter they're
all Muslims who want to destroy America
okay your question presupposes that
Islam is a single monolithic thing which
is just not factual no religious
tradition is ever only one thing all
religious traditions are massively
diverse like I am a Christian but
theologically I probably have more in
common with some liberal Muslims than I
do with some conservative Christians
religion is not just a set of practices
or a singular monolithic belief system
religion is a response to Revelation and
different people respond to revelation
differently we cannot continue to assume
that each religion represents only one
set of ideas the protesters are inspired
by Islam those who fight the protesters
are inspired by Islam the work we're
doing in Bangladesh is inspired by Islam
and the corrupt government of Bangladesh
is inspired by Islam it is not just one
thing with every revelation some people
respond by making the world better and
some respond by making it worse which is
true of religious revelations and
secular ones alike the revelation isn't
the problem
we are Hank you'll see me on Tuesday